So let's start building up these chained environments
through a series of function calls.
What will that look like?
Well, at some point we declare or define the function--some fun, we'll call it--
and then later on we call it.
We want to have some fun, and we're going to pass in as the actual arguments
three different expressions.
Here are the steps we go through.
First, we create a new environment, and its parent pointer points to the current environment.
This parent part is really essential.
Next, in that new environment we create storage places for each formal parameter.
Formal parameters, in this example, p1, p2, and p3.
There are three formal parameters.
Then you want to fill in those places with the values of the actual arguments.
The actual arguments are e1, e2, and e3.
Oh, no! There's a step 4.
Then you actually just do it.
You evaluate the function body in the new environment.
That means it's going to be able to see the values of the actual arguments,
which is just what we wanted.
Let's try this out with a bit of a quiz.
Here I've got a 5-line Python program.
X gets 1; Y gets 2.
I define a function, myfun, of formal parameters A, B, and X,
prints out A + B + X.
And then I make a call to myfun with actual arguments 1+2, 3+4, and 5+6.
I'm definitely going to have a global environment,
and when we call myfun, we want to make a new environment
pointing back to the old one,
which is going to have room for some new places.
But I haven't quite filled everything out, and I'm hoping you will help me.
We need to know the value of X and Y in the global environment
and then fill in these three boxes down here in this child environment
corresponding to the myfun function call. Fill in the blanks.